[Music]
hey
oh no i can't i can't hear you haley at
all unmute
yeah
hello hello hello nice nice to hear you
hello so nice to meet you
[Music]
hi i'm ross and marshall thurber and i'm
here talking with haley hope bartels who
just won the nico fellowship for her
fantastic script pumping black it is
about an aging cyclist in the 1990s who
when threatened with being cut from his
team right before the tour de france
takes up a dangerous offer from a team
doctor to engage in doping
congratulations on on pumping black and
on
being a nichols fellow i'm i
every morning i wake up and i'm waiting
for someone to be like there's been a
huge mistake
but it's so fun it's held so far so oh
yeah yeah it's not it's not a very
elaborate episode of punk uh yeah but
yeah so uh tell me a little bit about
submitting and what that uh process was
like yeah so i uh graduated afi
in 2019 a couple months after that the
pandemic hit
perfect and it was mostly like a sea of
no's applying to the nickel this year i
almost didn't
do it because i was like i keep sending
things to competitions and
people keep saying no i i asked my
boyfriend like should i apply to that
should i even apply the nickel this year
he's like yes you have to do it i was
like uh but they're not gonna like it
like they never like he's like you have
to apply it you just have to do it good
boyfriend what do you think it was about
um pumping black that the deciders liked
that that they maybe didn't see in your
previous writing this script is much
more specific and weird i think even
though it's a very
fantastical sort of specific world of
professional cycling in which i have
never personally lived the
element of perfectionism and obsession i
think that came out
in this script in a way that it hasn't
in my other writing it's a whole world
of um
of doping and racing in the tour de
france but there's not much of a mention
of one and only uh lance armstrong
that's very intentional yeah yeah the
story of lance armstrong is the doping
story that everybody knows maybe people
know
barry bonds i'm a giants fan like
oh
how are you doing it's not great
uh well you know it's a it's a really
powerful screenplay and i mean it's all
really really juicy stuff and
beautifully rendered in your work so i
i'm not surprised uh the least now that
you were selected so congratulations for
for you when you're writing what uh what
do you find is the most challenging part
of it for you is it is it the beginning
is it finishing uh do you get mired in
the middle i'm so happy you asked uh we
have a big
huge like eight by five white board and
i put my nine beats up or if i'm doing a
pilot and that is the most difficult
part once i've done that for
two three six months then i can write a
script in a week like pumping black like
first draft wrote in a week took me six
months to write it in a week i would
love your
advice on you know as somebody who's
been very successful in the industry
since at least 2006
um dodgeball's awesome by the way my dad
still quotes that movie all the time
tell your dad i'm a big fan i'm a big
fan of his he sounds like a very smart
man yeah he's a genius um that sounded
sarcastic but he is he is a very smart
man success in this town and maybe
success in any any competitive field you
know really comes down to three things
as far as i've been able to suss out um
and it's hard work uh luck and talent i
put in the hours and you know you're
butt in the seat working on the you know
on your screenplay and then i found that
the harder i work the luckier i i've
gotten you could have not written a
pumping black you could have not
submitted it had your boyfriend not made
you do it um but but you could have not
right like you could have said i'm tired
of being passed on and i'm gonna go
you know but you didn't and and uh and
and thank goodness for that right what
are you doing
next what's the what's the plan yeah
well i i gotta write a script for the
nico committee over the next year yeah i
gotta do that i haven't decided what
that's gonna be yet i wish you all the
best and congratulations on on winning
the nickel and uh and i'm stoked for you
and good luck truly like this has been
so delightful and i had the best time
thank you again and uh thank you thank
you thank you
giants
giants next year we're gonna get it yes
yes ma'am see you later
you